françois mitterrand alger première
visite en algérie depuis les événements
tragiques d'octobre est depuis des
réformes politiques
quinze morts à belfort tous moins 30 ans
l'enquète commente à peine sur ce
terrible incendie dû peut-être à des
négligence d'entretien les plus belles
sont en suisse c'est le salon auto de
genève en vedette les nouvelles
sportives les véhicules 4 4
la douche écossaise où les raisons d'une
piquette analyse douloureuse d'un échec
annoncé de l'équipe de france de foot
bonsoir et d'abord cette question de
médecine faut-il opérée à coeur ouvert
les personnes âgées de plus de 75 ans la
réponse aujourd'hui c'est oui et cela
donne beaucoup d'espoir à tous les gens
âgés qui souffrent du coeur l'année
dernière par exemple 2000 personnes dans
cette tranche d'âge ont bénéficié de la
chirurgie cardiaque
les progrès de cette chirurgie et de
l'anesthésique font que c'est maintenant
une opération sur et puis économiquement
car il faut bien aussi parlé de cela et
bien c'est tout à fait rentable car les
personnes âgées après l'opération
consomment moins de médicaments
daniel duigou alain gérard reportage cet
homme de 81 ans a subi une opération à
coeur ouvert
il y a trois mois il était condamné
aujourd'hui il vit avec une valve
artificielle est lui très bien vous êtes
heureux de retrouver votre jardin de
pouvoir retravailler pencher sur ça ça
ne manque pas j'ai pu le faire avant ah
ben alors umut au bout du rouleau body
et maintenant comment vous sentez vous
qu'est ce que vous faites lors de votre
journée dans ma journée est belle quand
je reprends pochette pascal rossoz non
c'est comme être au bout y ait d'autres
morts je vais me promener je ne reste
pas la maison sayari à nos frères et
moins comme ça oui je fais le tour je
cause avec avec l'autre
il y a dix ans un chirurgien n'aurait
jamais pris le risque d'opérer un homme
aussi âgée aujourd'hui n'hésite pas pour
trois raisons meilleure sélection des
malades meilleures techniques
chirurgicales meilleur
anesthésie-réanimation trois raisons 3
sécurité pour une opération délicate
changer une valve la valve aortique qui
ne fonctionne pratiquement plus voici la
nouvelle valve qui est déjà en place la
valve artificielle et qui elle marche
parfaitement bien mais pour qu'une telle
opération réussisse il existe une
condition essentielle elle n'a rien à
voir avec la technique médicale
il faut que la personne âgée est la
volonté farouche de vie après 75 ans si
le patient ne veut pas être amélioré
l'intervention ne marchera pas dans de
bonnes conditions car en post opératoire
il ne fera pas les efforts pour respirer
faire la kiné respiratoire et donc on
aura des complications premier avantage
de l'opération c'est l'amélioration
considérable de la vie des personnes
âgées concernées par ces pathologies
deuxième avantage c'est pour la société
faire des économies l'opération coûte
cher 50 mille francs
mais elle évite des dépenses encore plus
élevé en hospitalisation et en pharmacie
un argument économique a considéré dans
une société où la médecine va coûter de
plus en plus cher la corse la corse qui
s'enflamme brusquement à trois jours des
municipales c'est d'autant plus
préoccupant que le scrutin n'aura
peut-être même pas lieu à l'origine de
tout ça une grève une grève dans la
fonction publique qui dure depuis 18
jours qui a soudain dégénéré françoise
joly six personnes blessées à bastia une
ajaccio c'est le bilan des affrontements
aujourd'hui entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants
des manifestantes délogés par les
policiers alors qu'ils bloquaient
l'accès au préfecture de bastia et
d'ajaccio
la grève qui a débuté il ya trois
semaines dans l'île est suivie par 80 %
des salariés de la fonction publique
ils réclament une prime d'insularité
soit 1000 francs par mois et une
augmentation de 2 à 3 % de leurs
salaires une revalorisation qu'il juge
nécessaires pour compenser le coût de la
vie
plus élevé dit il que sur le continent
ce conflit se durcit et paralyse
maintenant la presque totalité des
services publics poste sécurité sociale
ou encore centre des impôts
un inspecteur des finances envoyé
spécial de matignon a rencontré des
responsables de l'administration et des
syndicalistes
il doit rendre son rapport au mois
d'avril la cgt elle de son côté demande
l'ouverture immédiate de négociations
le drame de belfort une tragédie
d'autant plus douloureuse que l'on sait
maintenant que les quinze personnes qui
ont péri dans cet incendie d'un immeuble
du centre ville de belfort donc toutes
ces personnes avaient moins de 30 ans
l'enquète commence à peine
on sait seulement que cet immeuble était
vieux et sans doute mal entretenu agnès
poirier
les pompiers ont laissé la place aux
enquêteurs depuis ce matin les
recherches ont cessé toute la nuit les
sauveteurs avaient fouillé les décombres
à la recherche de nouvelles victimes
trois étages se sont effondrés à
l'intérieur ça n'est plus qu'un tas de
gravats
les experts de la police scientifique
vont étudier les lieux le feu aurait pu
démarrer d'un local à poubelles au
rez-de-chaussée avant de gagner les
étages négligence court-circuit geste de
malveillance
l'heure est toujours aux hypothèses en
janvier dernier toute une série
d'incendiés criminels avaient été
allumés dans les quartiers populaires de
belfort et les locataires qui ont
échappé aux flammes
mettant course l'installation électrique
cet après midi jean pierre chevènement
maire de la ville a lancé un appel à
témoins afin de faire progresser
l'enquêté judiciaire
en quelques mois l'algérie s'est
transformé radicalement les émeutes
d'octobre ont entraîné des réformes en
profondeur
c'est un pays complètement changé que
françois mitterrand a visité ce jeudi
une visite de travail pour approfondir
les relations entre les deux pays
monsieur mitterrand a été accueillie
avec chaleur jean-michel mercurol
quatrième voyage en algérie mais 6e
tête-à-tête mitterrand chédeville ces
quelques heures de conversations
informelles voulu par les deux chefs
d'état souligna c'est la volonté de part
et d'autre de continuer d'apurer les
contentieux après l'accord sur les
achats de gaz algérien et l'ouverture
d'un crédit de 7 milliards de francs à
l'algérie petit à petit se raffermissent
les relations entre paris et alger
c'est sous la tente dans les jardins de
la résidence présidentielle de zéralda
que se sont déroulées les entretiens
destinés surtout à dresser le cadre d'un
programme d'avenir entre les deux pays
et d'en finir avec des relations souvent
au coup par coup
si rien n'a filtré de ces retrouvailles
les sujets des changes ne devait pas
manquer relations nord-sud proche orient
rapport du maghreb et de la cee un
moment de détente dans cette journée
avec la visite des ruines de tipasa cher
albert camus aujourd'hui en algérie en
ce mitterrand devient le tout premier
chef d'état occidental à rendre visite
au président chadli après les émeutes
d'octobre et la volonté de
démocratisation du régime
j'ai lu prades autres
respect que de redire le plaisir que
j'ai de me trouver à l'hgy de retrouver
votre pays il adressé au peuple algérien
l'expression de mes sentiments mes voeux
ce que je forme pour la réussite de ce
peuple et la réussite de ses
responsables robert lacoste qui vient de
mourir avait été ministre résident en
algérie sous le gouvernement de guy
mollet en 56 et 57 et bien mourir en
dordogne à l'âge de 91 ans il avait
occupé aussi plusieurs fonctions
ministérielles
pendant la quatrième république
l'enseignement
hier le gouvernement avait parlé aux
enseignants par le support de la
télévision trois quarts d'heures de
communication quasi direct forte écoute
et puisqu'il y avait un million quatre
cent mille téléspectateurs devant leur
poste
aujourd'hui même motif même horaire et
partis politiques ont répondu au
gouvernement l'opposition demande une
concertation générale
mais écoutons d'abord le pc dès
maintenant dès le printemps
dès le mois de mars il faut agir pour
imposer au gouvernement
une orientation qui fasse de la rentrée
1989 une vente et de rupture avec
l'échec et qui amorce une transformation
positive du système scolaire national
j'ai trouvé je crois que c'était aussi
le sentiment de michel avec qui j'en ai
parlé que c'était un peu une émission de
circonstance on avait le sentiment que à
trois jours des élections municipales
il s'agissait pour monsieur rocard et
pour monsieur jospin de retenir des
électeurs qui ont un peu la tentation de
quitter le parti socialiste
je voudrais sincèrement que sur
l'éducation
on arrive à trouver le moyen de parler
de parler entre les partis politiques au
parlement wire et de parler avec
l'ensemble des acteurs du système sur
vous pour mission de là n'oubliez au cas
moi je suis prêt à discuter avec le
gouvernement
toutefois rien n'est bien sûr pas
m'asseoir autour d'une table avec avec
les lutins sur vrai tout de même que
l'enseignement l'éducation nationale
souffre d'un certain nombre de maladies
qui prend vielle jeu lire un peu
d'idéologie socialiste c'est l'idéologie
que tous les professeurs sont pareils
les écoles doivent être différentes
donc ces maladies et l'hyper
centralisation
lippert syndicalisation de notre système
éducatif quand nous nous comparons aux
autres nous avons un certain nombre de
maladies
et c'est vrai que ces maladies ont
souvent été porté par l'idéologie
socialiste et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je crois que le dr carr et le
dr jose pas sont pas les meilleurs
docteurs pour soigner cette maladie et
lionel jospin ministre de l'éducation
répondra peut-être ce soir à la
proposition de monsieur juppé d'une
concertation
monsieur jospin est à toulouse social
d'abord reprise du travail aux nmpp
demain donc il y aura de nouveau des
journaux dans vos kiosques les grévistes
de la cgt n'ont pas voulu qu'on filme à
17 heures la reprise de leurs activités
en revanche dans le secteur de la santé
les infirmières anesthésistes poursuivre
leur grève demain et les internes
menacent de reprendre leur mouvement
avec les chefs des cliniques les chefs
de clinique
les 15 et 16 mars les municipales cette
fois se rapproche vraiment j moins 3 ce
soir dunkerque sous la loupe une ville
où le scrutin va être très très serré
jusqu'à présent le maire claude
prouvoyeur gagner largement
mais michel delebarre actuel ministre du
gouvernement a débarqué pour le parc
pour le parti socialiste et tout bouge
brusquement à dunkerque laurent boussier
patrick gab et reportages
quant au mois de décembre dernier michel
delebarre a annoncé sa candidature à la
mairie de dunkerque la nouvelle a fait
l'effet d'une bombe dans le nord tout le
monde attendait l'ex futur héritier de
pierre mauroy à lille et dunkerque se
préparer à une campagne municipale
classique voire banal mais la succession
du maire de lille n'étant pas à l'ordre
du jour
le ministre des transports et de
l'équipement est venue à dunkerque à la
plus grande joie des socialistes locaux
un challenge difficile pour michel
delebarre dans une ville tenue depuis 23
ans par le sénateur maire claude
prouvoyeur un temps que michel delebarre
juge suffisants ils sont là depuis un
quart de siècle
leur caractéristique l'immobilisme et
clientélisme voilà les deux
caractéristiques la gestion dunkerquoise
aujourd'hui ce que nous voulons faire et
tous ceux qui sont autour de moi sur la
liste ou battre on l'a bien de dunkerque
troisième port français construction
européenne
attirer des entreprises voilà deux
objectifs créer des emplois pour cela il
faut une équipe dynamique il faut avoir
une ambition pour dunkerque
parti avec près de 10 points de retard
sur son concurrent michel delebarre a
réussi à faire l'union à gauche ps pc
mrg écologistes personnalités locales
sont sur sa liste sa campagne est menée
tambour battant il passe quatre à cinq
jours par semaine à dunkerque un
déploiement de force qui n'impressionne
pas claude prouvoyeur élu et réélu au
premier tour depuis 23 ans il a tout
vécu avec sa ville usine hors norme est
de 12 mille licenciements et les
problèmes économiques
aujourd'hui alors que l'embellie pointe
son nez
il trouve anormal qu'un autre en tire
les bénéfices
michel delbarre arrive auréolé de son
titre de ministre
les dunkerquois peut-être certains se
laisseront séduire par cette étiquette
mais si l'on constate ce que michel
delbarre a fait de 80 86 lorsqu'il était
au gouvernement au directeur de cabinet
de pierre mauroy et on se rend vite
compte que derrière rien fait à ce
moment là il ya peu de chances qu'il
fasse quelque chose maintenant
et puis dans cette bataille arrive le
front national sans pouvoir espérer
accéder à la mairie
il peut jouer les trouble fête pour nous
le combat delebarre pourvoyeur c'est le
combat de crocodile solidaire du même
système
ceci étant dit nous au front national
nous n'avons jamais fait la politique du
pire et nous saurons faire votre choix à
48 heures du scrutin plus personne n'ose
faire de pronostic
cette élection se jouera dans un
mouchoir l'abstention pouvant être
fatale à l'un ou l'autre des candidats
demain aux 4 vérités tu es dans
télématin à 7h45 gérard morin continuera
de recevoir les grands leaders
politiques demain alain juppé secrétaire
général du rpr puis sachez enfin que
tout ce que vous voulez savoir sur les
municipales et bien vous pouvez le
trouver très facilement grâce à notre
minitel des renseignements innombrables
sur le scrutin commune par commune
alors vous faites simplement sur le
minitel 36 15 codes à 2
la fin du contrôle des changes en france
un contrôle qui aura duré 20 ans il
avait en effet été institué en 68 au
lendemain des événements en fait ce
contrôle des changes gérard leclerc il
s'était peu à peu adouci oui et c'est
aujourd'hui une décision très symbolique
la plupart des restrictions à la
circulation des capitaux avaient été
effectivement levé ces trois dernières
années mais l'abrogation du décret pris
au lendemain de la tourmente de mai 68
de nos
entreprise une liberté qu'elle n'avait
pratiquement jamais connu sauf dans les
années 60 la construction d'une europe
monétaire était à ce prix
les marchés l'ont interprété comme un
signe de confiance vis-à-vis du franc
qui a retrouvé son niveau le plus haut
depuis sept mois face au mark allemand
cela liste contrôle des changes
supprimer donc tout reste encore à faire
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire ce lien
absolument oui avant que les
particuliers puissent l'an prochain
placé leurs économies où bon leur semble
en europe il faudra pour éviter les
fuites de capitaux à harmoniser les
fiscalités des douze sur l' épargne la
bataille s'annonce rude et la france il
laissera quelques milliards en rentrées
fiscales et puis l'abandon du contrôle
des changes avec cet abandon la france
l'économie française perd son dernier
filet de sécurité en cas de dérapage
économique
rien n'arrêtera désormais la chute du
franc merci gérard le procès du
commissaire jobic à nanterre le
commissaire joe big est accusée vous le
savez de proxénétisme aggravé il aurait
abusé de sa position de policiers à mi
chemin de ce procès c'est justement la
police qui était mise en cause et ses
méthodes critiquées
rémy roches à nanterre si je dis que
choisit d'être policier c'est par
vocation et pour rien d'autre surtout
pas pour l'argent
il l'a dit clairement au président foule
qui devait peu après le féliciter pour
ses brillantes études et un début de
carrière de commissaire considéré comme
tout à fait prometteur par ses
supérieurs en quatre ans lui et ses
hommes v8 recherche de la 1ère division
de police judiciaire avait réussi à
déférer quelques consent délinquants à
la justice et si le président se montre
convaincu du train de vie apparemment
tout à fait normal du commissaire
confirmé d'ailleurs par rapport d
expertise financière
il va se montrer semble-t-il moins
satisfaits par les réponses de joe big
sur les rapports qu'il entretenait avec
ses informateurs certes ce n'est pas
aujourd'hui que l'on découvre le rôle
des indics dans le travail
voir dans le succès des policiers
empêche qu il semble bien qu avec
certains d'entre eux aujourd'hui inculpé
de proxénétisme ou de trafic de drogue
le commissaire entretiennent des
rapports d'une certaine familiarité
voire de proximité dira le président
foulquier on entre tout juste dans le
vif du sujet car toute la question c'est
bien sûr de savoir si ces relations
quel qu'en soit le mode était
strictement professionnel ou si l on tue
pour le commissaire joe big d
implication plus personnel
les finances du vatican vont mal et son
ancien grand argentier monseigneur
martin cus a été poussé vers la porte de
la banque du vatican
le trou dans le budget du saint-siège
dépassera 78 millions de dollars cette
année en 89 contrats manquante à
monseigneur martin kusch le prélat le
plus tristement célèbres du vatican et
bien son nom avait été mêlé à de
nombreux scandales
marcel trillât il va nous manquer fils
d'un immigré lituanien aux états unis
grand joueur de golf devant l'éternel
monseigneur paul martin qui s'était
depuis 1959 du haut de ses 1 mètre 91
l'un des piliers du temple le colosse de
rome ces pôles si ce qu'il avait appelé
auprès de lui organiser ses voyages à
l'étranger
le gorille que diplomate il poursuivi
jusqu'en 1982 avec jean paul ii cette
activité dans laquelle il semblait avoir
trouvé son chemin de damas mais c'est
surtout comme banquier qu'il passera à
la postérité
depuis plus de vingt ans il était le pdg
de l'institut pour les oeuvres de
religion
la banque du vatican un poste de
confiance où il avait été parachuté sans
aucune compétence sa carrure de gardes
du corps ne lui fut malheureusement pas
d'un grand secours pour affronter les
requins de la finance italienne
deux d'entre eux auquel il avait
peut-être un peu imprudemment lier le
sort de sa pieuse entreprises
l'entraîneur dans les plus retentissants
scandales financiers de ces dernières n
michele sindona homme d'affaires en
odeur de mafia arraché à l'affection des
siens en 1986 dans une prison italienne
par un café au cyanure
roberto calvi le patron de la banque
ambrosiano retrouvé pendu sous un pont
de londres en 1980 de bilan pour les
finances du vatican un trou de 1
milliard 600 millions de fois
apparemment abandonnée par la providence
divine pour chasser un temps par la
justice italienne
monseigneur marc chine pousse avait
pourtant conservé la confiance de jean
paul ii pour lui éviter une humiliante
révocation on a tout simplement supprimé
son poste il sera remplacé par un
directeur sans doute lake contrôlé par
un conseil de cinq experts
tous de bons catholiques bien sûr mais
tous de vrais professionnels de la
banque
c'est plus prudent autres pays autres
moeurs mais toujours le scandale c'est
la fere tower aux etats-unis le sénat se
prépare à refuser deux mains que john
towers soit secrétaire à la défense
il aime trop les femmes l'argent et
l'alcool pas forcément dans cet ordre
d'ailleurs quoi qu'il en soit ce sera un
coup dur pour george bush
mais cette affaire s'explique quand on
connaît la société américaine shaka
bouchard à washington confirmant john
towers au pentagone pour six mois à
l'essai c'était l'ultime baroud
d'honneur du leader républicain bob dole
au sénat pour sauver la candidature du
ministre de la défense désigné échec
total
malgré le ralliement in extremis de
l'oeil benson qui fut le seconde dukakis
dans la course à la maison blanche avant
le vote
les derniers pointages crédité john
towers de 46 voix sur il lui en faudrait
50 pour passer la défaite prévisible
sera avant tout celle de george bush
il s'est acharné ou imposer son poulain
malgré un climat hostile ses frasques
amoureuses son penchant excessif pour
l'alcool ont desservi john towers autre
handicap son action comme conseiller
grassement rétribués par des sociétés
sous contrat avec le pentagone george
bush va devoir repartir à zéro pour le
ministère de la défense
et l'on mentionne le nom de brent
scowcroft un général à la retraite qui
est son conseiller pour les affaires de
sécurité nationale
cette affaire terreur laissera des
traces depuis cinq jours capitole elle
donne lieu à de sévères empoignades mais
surtout elle porte un coup sérieux à
l'état de grâce qui accompagne
l'installation du nouveau président
george bush voulait fermer le cornell
reggane il souhaitait enterrer la hache
de guerre avec le congrès à majorité
démocrate
or après 50 jours de maison blanche il
est en plein affrontement cette
information une histoire d'espionnage à
washington un attaché militaire
soviétique vient d'être expulsé des
etats-unis pour espionnage
il a été surpris en train de recevoir
des informations confidentielles de la
part d'un américain travaillant dans une
société avec lequel le gouvernement
fasse des contrats
la sphère rushdie les procédures
d'expulsion d'iraniens ont commencé en
grande bretagne il s'agit de neuf
employés de l'ex ambassades d'iran à
londres et à propos de la sphère rushdie
la suite de notre enquête que nous
menons toute la semaine sur les
répercussions internationales de cette
affaire et notamment dans les diverses
communautés musulmanes hier et
avant-hier nous avons parlé de la
poussée de l'islam en algérie et aussi
de la communauté musulmane en grande
bretagne ce soir l'allemagne avec ce
reportage de philippe rochot à l'ombre
de la cathédrale de cologne
la première communautés musulmanes
d'allemagne fédérale les turcs un
million cinq cent mille fidèles de
l'islam les à l'islam sous haute
surveillance depuis que le cheikh kaplan
chefs religieux rallier à khomeiny a
appelé au renversement du régime turc
il aura fallu plus d'un mois aux
musulmans pour se mobiliser contre les
versets sataniques
les 5000 croyants ont crié leur colère
contre salman rushdie manifestation
plutôt bon enfant la majorité ici ne
veut pas de confrontation
ce n'est pas la guerre
le livre de rouge qui n'est pas le
premier du genre et ne sera pas le
dernier
les médias ont amplifié le problème
alors qu'on ne connaît pas le contenu du
livre
une chose est pourtant certaine il faut
respecter le coran est notre prophète
car il a fait le bien dans tous les
domaines de même su pardonner à ceux qui
avaient trouvé dans l'industrie
automobile un tiers des ouvriers sont
musulmans mais ici pas de mouvement
contre le livre de rouge dit une forte
pression sociale des ouvriers allemands
freine les extrémistes qui voudraient
manifester
les positions restent nuancé
les plus rapides à descendre dans la rue
ont été finalement les opposant iranien
les moudjahidine du peuple dont les
effectifs ont sérieusement augmenté
depuis que plusieurs centaines d'entre
eux ont quitté la france
je crois que khomeiny n'est pas musulman
il est même l'ennemi numéro 1 de l'islam
du coran et du prophète au nom de
l'islam il a exécuté des milliers de
prisonniers politiques et sur la scène
européenne il a soutenu le terrorisme
il ne peut pas être cité comme musulman
il n'a pas le droit de donner des ordres
ni de juger ce livre à bonn le parlement
fédéral a dénoncé l'appel au meurtre de
khomeiny comme une déclaration de guerre
les députés verts et socialistes ont
obtenu le gel des négociations
économiques avec téhéran mais demande
d'autres mesures malgré la fermeté
allemande les mots d'ordre de khomeiny
ont des échos ici l'éditeur et protégé
alors que la traduction des versets
sataniques signé de 30 auteurs ne
sortira qu'à l'automne des librairies
ont déjà reçu des menaces
seul à berlin le quotidien la tâte a
publié les passages les plus sensibles
des versets sataniques
seule note appuyée dans une presse et
une télévision restait plutôt sobre sur
l' affaire salman rushdie d'autres
informations internationales en bref
avec éric perrin est tout d'abord la
sphère des missiles pour le congo hier
l'élysée avait annulé une exportation de
missiles mistral vers ce pays
interpellation à tignes de thierry
miailhe est soupçonné d'être
l'intermédiaire entre la société matra
et le congo pour l'achat de 50 missiles
mistral en fait destinée à un autre pays
figurant sur la liste rouge
au congo on indique que le colonel
voyante délai également mis en cause
serait victime d'un règlement de comptes
interne la société matra fabricant du
mistral a décidé de porter plainte
contre x
tirs de roquettes de la résistance
afghane sur l'aéroport de kaboul un
porte parole du gouvernement a indiqué
que l'armée régulière avaient repoussé
l'offensive lancée hier par les
moudjahidine sur djalal-abad ville
stratégique située entre kaboul la
capitale et le pakistan où sont basés
les rebelles ces derniers continuent
leur offensive sur l'aéroport de djalal
abad
lire at échappe à la condamnation de la
commission des droits de l'homme de
l'onu la résolution condamnant bagdad
pour l'utilisation d'armes chimiques
contre les civils kurdes n'aura même pas
été mise aux voix
amnesty international auteur d'un
rapport accablant notamment sur la
torture d'enfants s'est déclaré
profondément troublé par cette décision
ouverture ce matin du salon automobile
de genève c'est l'un des événements pour
l'industrie automobile et pour le public
un salon qui décoiffe car la mode
revient doucement à la vitesse et à l'
aventure en vedette en effet les
voitures sportives et aussi les 4,4 à
l'adouber ce qui examine les plus de ce
salon de genève allons directement vers
la plus rapide la honda nsx 250 km heure
un moddeur ces soupapes elle atteint les
5 km heure en moins de 6 secondes une
carrosserie tout aluminium son prix
environ 500 mille francs
si le moteur est nerveux le client lui
devrait être patient la production ne
débutera que dans un an et maintenant là
peut-être que ça lors la voiture la plus
sophistiquée la cause en avance au
niveau technologique a plus haut rhin la
plus tôt la mercedes 500 et celle des
cabriolets il en existe depuis longtemps
mais celui ci adopte toutes les
solutions techniques d'avant-garde
suspension arrière avec amortisseurs
adaptable arbres à cames à calage
variable dix possibilités de réglage du
siège et du volant
la liste des plus technologique est
impressionnante son prix aussi
d'ailleurs
environ 550 mille francs
la plus récente malgré les apparences de
déjà vu c'est la nouvelle ford fiesta
une carrosserie classique qui rappelle
quelque chose
les efforts ont porté sur l'habitacle
plus spacieux que l'ancien modèle
pourquoi se priver du plaisir d'examiner
la plus chère c'est une rolls bien sûr
le modèle corniche convertibles 1
million 300 mille francs à ce prix là on
ne pose plus de questions techniques
ce serait de mauvais goût maintenant
l'évolution la plus spectaculaire celle
des 4 4 c'est à dire des véhicules
quatre roues motrices
il y a peu de temps seuls des véhicules
du type jeep en étaient équipés
aujourd'hui des berlines familiales
citroën renault ou peugeot le propose
bien d'autres marques encore évidemment
pour terminer la plus élégante la plus
rare classique tiffany fabriqués par
ford lincoln chaussée par michelin une
conception moderne sous une carrosserie
rétro 50% de la production est exportée
vers les pays arabes du golfe
cinq cent mille francs c'est moins cher
qu'une rolls et puis ça fait presque
autant d'effet le sport paris-nice
d'abord beaucoup de changements dans
l'étape qui arrivait au mont faron tout
à leur victoire d'étape du français
bruno cornillet le leader laurent des
eaux malade a dû abandonner comme fignon
hier et c'est un autre français marc
madiot qui a endossé le maillot blanc de
leader
en foot la douche écossaise c'était bien
une douche et c'était bien en écosse il
a plu des trombes à glasgow pendant tout
le match qui a vu la victoire de
l'ecosse par 2 à 0 sur l'équipe de
france
sale temps pour platini le sélectionneur
sale temps pour tout le football
français qui n'ira sans doute pas en
coupe du monde en italie raison d'une
défaite francis maroteaux pendant dix
ans cet homme a contribué au succès de
l'équipe de france de football
1976 1986 âge d'or du football français
avec michel platini et la génération
giresse tigana et autres dominique
rocheteau époque d'un milieu de terrain
magique efficace oui mais retrait des
anciens restent les jeunes
cette génération que l'on a tendance à
taxer génération surpayés dit on à tel
point que l'équipe de france ne peut
même plus se payer un billet pour le
mondial et italiens alors où est le mal
sur le terrain le milieu de terrain
bijoux naguère ne brille plus du même
éclat mais il tient mieux même face au
britannique l'aurait tire le premier
alors la défense deux erreurs françaises
de du et que c'est sur la première
action de johnston l'aurait de ce chat
lien ne remonte pas assez vite
1 0 pour les causses et les vrais
problèmes commencent car en fait la
france ne marque plus de buts
résultat on se découvre et nouveau coup
de froid mauvais dégagement de sonore
johnston seul entre trois français
pousse bats à la foule mais que dire de
la tacc les français se créent deux
occasions où pourraient s'en crée pas
peint tout seul pousse trop loin son
ballon
manque de lucidité le marseillais encore
lui oriente son amorti de la poitrine
mais sa frappe manque de puissance de
hargne manque de hargne encore avec
cette passe de stéphane paille pau le
gardien écossais incroyable il faut
réapprendre à marquer même pour le
meilleur buteur actuel du championnat de
france
jean pierre papin il faut aussi lire et
apprendre à traverser une défense autre
aveu d'impuissance christian pérez longe
la surface et devant l'absence de
solution il frappe pied droit lui le
gaucher
dès lors que faire que nous tiendrons
plus d'expérience ou vous qui pouvez les
mettre au pied du mur c'est peut-être
bien et nokia ont plus d'expérience on
peut peut-être aidé à être bien pendant
90 minutes
alors il leur reste quatre fois 90
minutes pour créer un petit miracle tout
gagner et puis surtout espérer voit la
fin de cette édition du journal tout de
suite la météo avec laurent cabrol tout
doux le temps comme cabrol d'ailleurs
vers lé journal ce sera philippe gassot
vers minuit après édition spéciale de
claude sérillon consacré aux
expropriations télématin demain ça
commence à 6h45 avec roger zabel
françois push les et toute leur équipe
voilà fin de soi afin de saxe édition
pardon excellente soirée sur antenne 2 à
demain 20 heures
non
à